if i die
the dogs will fix me
hey guys pete here today i've got a
quick expanse video to address some
questions about the finale and those
opening scenes on laconia i also have to
mention that today's video is brought to
you by squarespace stand out online with
a professional website online store or
portfolio with squarespace the expanse
season 6 is the final season of the
series as far as we know there are three
more novels that continue the story and
we do hope that they will someday be
adapted but for now this is all there is
so a lot of viewers have been asking
what was the point of introducing us to
kara and zan this clearly sets up things
for later so why take time out of each
episode if you're not sure you're ever
going to be able to pay things off we
got into this in the finale live stream
discussion we did and i was the only one
that seemed to be in favor of including
the scenes and also happened to be the
only one who'd read the complete story
through book nine so in this video i'll
reiterate the point i made there and
there's also an interview with the
creators that we can look at where they
were asked the same question and
addressed it for spoilers i'll be
talking about everything that happened
in the show through the season 6 finale
and some details from the strange dogs
novella if you're not caught up then
this video might not be for you and with
that out of the way let's jump into it
so there's one thing that influences my
thinking that you might have missed in
the show's version of kara and zan's
story for background kara and her family
came to the planet with the initial
survey group from earth and then the
breakaway fleet arrived from mars and
essentially took over there's a
classroom scene where the soldier who's
talking to the kids says those of you
who've been here longer can help people
like me who came later by telling us
about anything that seems different or
changed especially in the last few weeks
he doesn't really explain why he wants
to know this information in the book he
says you've probably noticed that the
orbital platforms have been activated
and in the show you're just supposed to
put that together when you look at all
these scenes as a whole and they show
you this rather than tell you when
duarte is looking up and you see that
there's some kind of construction going
on the implication is the same bringing
the active protomolecule sample to the
planet does activate the gate builder
tech that was left behind after their
extinction this is similar to what the
crew of the ross and nante saw happen on
illus in season four but the laconians
think they're in a better position to
control what happens they brought
cortazar along who knows more about the
protomolecule than most and they have
the illest incident to look at and draw
some lessons from there are still a ton
of unknowns though and the strange dogs
that cara encounters are just one
example of something they couldn't
anticipate this is the kind of change
the soldier was asking the kids about
bringing the proto-molecule to the
planet was what woke the dog-like
creatures up cara saw them as a tool to
solve her problems which included
bringing her brother back from the dead
and that all stemmed from her being too
young to have developed the healthy fear
of the unknown she would need in that
situation she had a problem she couldn't
solve she needed some help and they were
there to provide it so maybe you picked
up on that while you were watching but i
know some of the people i talked to
missed it and just wanted to make sure
that was clear
in a polygon interview that just came
out with the showrunner naren shankar
and the two authors ty frank and daniel
abraham they asked them why they wanted
to include strange dogs in the first
place the showrunner said it was a way
to connect the events of season six to
the big questions that ended season five
it was about who marco was working with
how he managed to get a hold of the
martian ships he paid them with the
proto-molecule and cortazar so they
thought they should show what happened
when they took that through the ring
plus you had the ending of season 5
where you saw the bar keith get eaten as
it transited the ring he said there was
a way to deal with all these questions
and also not lose some focus on the
proto-molecule which was really the
thing that has always been at the center
i absolutely agree with this and would
add that introducing what's happening
there is important for when you see
duarte refuse further help to marco and
tell him that they're cutting off access
to the laconia ring this sets up a nice
enduring mystery something to think
about to contemplate after everything is
wrapped up in soul system i think for
those reasons alone that it's worth
including but i think there's a better
reason baked in and i'll get to that in
a minute after i talk about something
much less mysterious the sponsor of
today's video is squarespace recently i
wanted to put together a website and i
found squarespace to be really
user-friendly it was simple to jump
right in and start to create a website
or you could put together an online
store with marketing tools and analytics
built in for what i was looking to do
the video blocks were great just paste
the url and upload a custom thumbnail
and i appreciated that all the templates
have built-in mobile websites just make
it once and it looks great across all
devices while you're working you can
toggle the views back and forth and get
the design just how you like it check
out squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
pete peppers to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain i
brought up the enduring mystery of
what's going to happen on laconia and
now that zan has been brought back to
life by a creature that appeared after
an active protomolecule sample was
brought to the planet it's been
established that the proto-molecule was
used to build roads by an advanced
civilization that's been extinct for
billions of years they sent out probes
containing the protomolecule and that
hijacked any primitive life that was
available and went on to create a ring
which then connected to the ringgate
network the one that they sent to our
solar system got trapped in saturn's
orbit so it wasn't able to build its
gate until humans evolved enough to be
able to travel that far from earth and
discover it we know that much but it's
still completely mysterious and it's the
kind of situation where just when you
think you might understand something
about it you realize you're only seeing
part of the picture when they were asked
the creators said that what you see is
that people think they understand it and
they try to bend it to their will only
to discover that there's something else
going on so the bottom line turns out to
be that we could not understand it and
that's been a big part of the story
throughout ty frank brought up the story
they used to explain this about a bunch
of monkeys that found a microwave they
have no context so one of them opens up
the door and he realizes you can put
things inside when you open the door a
light comes on so they think it's a way
to illuminate the darkness and another
one says this is really heavy and i can
break things with it so it's a handy
weapon for getting stuff you can use a
microwave for all of these things but a
monkey has never reheated a frozen
burrito so a big thing about the
proto-molecule is people keep saying it
must be this and to quote thai and we're
always wrong because the context in
which the proto-molecule was created and
the species that created it we share no
context with and so as naren said we
keep breaking ourselves on this because
we don't understand it and in many ways
we will never be able to understand it
so we'll just keep beating each other to
death with it thinking it's a big rock
and i think that's why it's important to
include this story as part of season six
which all things considered had a
hopeful and somewhat happy ending at
least the war came to a conclusion and
humanity moved in a positive direction
in relation to the divisions between
people in our solar system the point
being that humanity is complicated but
we do skew more towards good rather than
evil and this shows how delicate any
progress that comes from that can be
with something like the proto-molecule
there will always be someone who will
emerge to try to use it to their
advantage and what i always liked about
the story strange dogs was that it was
told from the perspective of a child in
a lot of ways humanity hasn't behaved
much better than children in their
interactions with it or if you prefer
than a bunch of monkeys who discovered a
microwave part of what drives men like
jewel pierre mao or in this case winston
duarte is the belief that if they don't
try to control the proto-molecule
someone else will and they aren't
necessarily wrong about that in my next
video i'll get into why duarte made his
move through the ring gate and for now i
think this is a good place to leave
things let me know your thoughts about
including karen's and story in season
six how you think it worked out did it
make sense and do you think it added to
a more complete story please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon